we have been saying this is the biggest
abuse of power corruption scandal in
American history now we know Barack
Obama Joe Biden Susan Rice Sally Yates
mr. super Patriot Jim Comey higher
lowest honor on earth have been exposed
what we're about to show you
it should anger every American it should
shake you to your core it should send a
shiver up your spine if you love our
Constitution and you love freedom and
you believe in the rule of law because
all of these high ranking bad actors now
must be held accountable or we can kiss
this great Republic goodbye that's how
serious it is then I based on what we
can report and that is newly uncovered
bombshell handwritten notes from yep
Peter struck himself revealing the sick
the twisted origins of the general Flynn
probe in a memo detailing the infamous
remember we talked about that timeline
January 5th meeting in the Oval Office
the White House by the way still a lot
of it redacted and I'm told when we get
that information it's even worse Peter
struck detailing the brainstorming
session between Obama Biden Comey Sally
Yates and others this was one day after
the Flynn case was done shut close
because they had no evidence of anything
inappropriate this meeting focusing on
how to destroy lieutenant general Flynn
according to struck then FBI director
Jim Comey he stated quote yeah Flynn's
kids lyac holes they appear legit
meaning they did nothing wrong because
the investigation proved and now the
transcripts show nothing was ever wrong
about that call like the president's
call with szalinski that did not stop
the Democratic presidential nominee Joe
Biden who brought up quote the Logan Act
to go after general Flynn
now remember yes that's the law from
1799 that has never been used keep in
mind all of this after they exonerate a
33-year veteran and war hero Obama
clearly approving saying that oh these
are unusual times that Obama and the
Oval Office
saying that his team should quote have
the right people on it
remember struck said the White House
wanted to be informed every step of the
way let me translate what Obama's saying
for you Obama wanted anti Trump zealots
who were ready and willing to take down
general Flynn by the way should I be
telling the Trump transition team we're
not telling them things now we know why
the 7th floor the FBI the day before
along with Peter struck decided to
reopen a closed case against general
Flynn after it was dead in the water 24
hours earlier now we know why Susan Rice
wrote the biggest cya email to herself
on Donald Trump's inauguration date 15
days later Obama's last day in office
saying Barack wanted everything to be
done by the book he said by the book by
the book and we also know why Sally
Yates when she spoke to the House
Intelligence Committee was shocked to
discover that day that President Obama
knew every detail about Flynn and his
phone conversations now we started this
investigation of March of 2017 we also
now know why Lisa page texted that Obama
wants to know everything we are doing
now we know what the insurance policy
was all about if Donald Trump happened
to win after they protected Hillary
Clinton from the Espionage Act and
obstruction of justice and her dirty
Russian disinformation dossier this all
came from the very top the Obama
administration Obama loyalists and the
DOJ they were hell-bent smearing
destroying anybody and Donald Trump's
orbit why because they wanted to undo a
duly elected president because they
thought they knew better now we know why
Roger stone had a pre-dawn raid in the
middle of the night 29 guys in tactical
gear and CNN cameras now we know why
same with Paul Manafort
now we know why he had a pre-dawn raid
sticking guns and his wife's face and
throwing in him in solitary confinement
so that he might say things that would
get him off the hook
which he didn't now we know why
Papadopoulos was
with years in prison when all he said is
I would never do that nobody ever talked
to Russia this was all in the end a
means to the end they wanted to turn the
screws and take down the president that
you the American people elected that is
called an attempted coup and by the way
Joe Biden are you really unable to
remember the January 5th meeting will
you offer it up the Logan act as a means
of persecuting and prosecuting and
destroying the life of general Flynn or
are you just a liar I'm actually betting
you're a liar take a look so what did
you know about those moves to
investigate Michael Flynn and was there
anything improper done I know nothing
about those moves to investigate Michael
Flynn I do want to press that you say
you didn't know anything about it but
you were reported to be in a January 5th
2017 meeting where you and the president
were briefed on the FBI's plan to
question Oh Michael Michael Flynn over
those conversations he had with the
Russian ambassador his lyac no I thought
you asked me whether or not I had
anything to do with him being prosecuted
okay I'm sorry I was aware that there
was that there were asked for an
investigation but that's all I know
I was never apart or had any knowledge
of any in criminal investigation into
Flynn while I was in office period not
one single time not a part of any
investigation into Flynn that's a lie
not a part of the Logan Act Joe that's a
lie not a part of the January fifth
meeting that's a lie Joe what did Joe
know what did Barak know what did Comey
know what did McKay page struck know
what it's alley eights know and when did
they know it now I know tonight many of
you have been frustrated because the
wheels of justice have move painfully
slow yours it truly as well the first we
first started on this with unmasking
illegal surveillance leaking raw
intelligence in March of 2017 I also
want to know a clapper of Brennan knew
and ever since this program and our
ensemble cast here every single night we
have reported to you the truth and by
the way my source
are now telling me tonight the dam is
about to burst wide open and that a
truckload of all new evidence is on the
way
the Durham probe is real it has made
real progress and thank God now if this
can happen to Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn nobody in this country is safe in
that terms of abusing the power and
using the powerful tools of intelligence
and turning him on American heroes like
general Flynn he was a hero 33-year
veteran multiple tours of duty he served
this country with honor and with
distinction and four years of his life
was ripped away by these top well so
called leaders the 1% that abused their
power he lost his house he faced
bankruptcy they threatened to put his
son in jail used it as leverage even
though they didn't feel like he was
lying so in other words oh yeah I have
to sign this or you're going to go after
my son well he impaled himself and dove
on the sword I guess like any good
loving father would do all of this
because his political connection at
Donald Trump and the mob and the media
that despicable repulsive group the
country's very own democratic state run
Pravda they cheered for the persecution
of general Flynn when are you in the mob
go to apologize hey Humpty Dumpty that
means your fake news network
Roswell Rachel Maddow that means your
conspiracy TV network that means that
New York toilet paper Times The
Washington compost ABC NBC CBS you all
Oh general Flynn a huge apology for what
you said and did and your lack of
objectivity and your lies about Russia
and Ukraine
you might remember did Flynn go rogue by
the way when he spoke to Russia
well fact is Michael Flynn betrayed his
country Michael Flynn betrayed the
nation after two hours of a judge
rebuking fired National Security Advisor
Michael Flint using words such as
treason disgust and disdain